Well, we sort of used the same tricks
that we've been talking about so far.
If you are executing user code,
you are in user mode.
You're not in system mode.
And we know that protected resources
are implemented by the operating system.
And so that data structures,
the information that is necessary for
us to access those protected resources
lives in the operating system
part of the address base.
And we know that while you're executing
the user code, you can't access that.
You have to switch to the system
mode through a system call.
And since you can't directly access it,
you don't have the information
that is necessary for
you to access a resource without
going through the operating system.
Which helps us with this complete
mediation property we have.
In addition, the user code can not
access physical resources because
often times they require execution
of privileged instructions.
We're talking about service
interrupts and things like that.
There's no way for
you to get to a disk lock.
Or change the register that
points to a page table,
because those are instructions
that are privileged.
And if you tried executing
them in the user mode,
your execution would be aborted.
You won't be able to continue that.
So complete mediation, again relies on
the same hardware mechanisms we've been
talking about where the isolation
mechanism we discussed the idea of
privileged instructions
that we discussed.